en este vídeo voy a trabajar con ustedes
con la curva de la demanda de dos
productos distintos en primer lugar les
presento a una computadora portátil
mientras que en segundo lugar tengo un
automóvil pero voy a pensar que es el
automóvil más barato del mercado aunque
esta foto fue tomada en 1985 pero bueno
imaginemos que es el auto más barato que
existe actualmente en el mercado y bueno
como quiero comprar las dos curvas de
demanda entonces voy a dibujar la
primera curva de la demanda y aquí
tenemos los ejes precio contra cantidad
demandada mientras que el otro también
en el eje vertical tengo el precio
mientras que en el eje horizontal tengo
la cantidad demandada y bueno vamos a
decir que ambos productos satisfacen la
ley de la demanda recuerden que esto
quiere decir que si nosotros tenemos un
precio muy alto pues por lo tanto la
cantidad de personas que compran el
producto es muy baja y viceversa y
siguiendo esta lógica voy a intentar
dibujar la curva de la demanda que aquí
parece muy recta no forzosamente tiene
que ser una recta por lo tanto voy a
dibujar algo un poco más coreado qué es
esto esta va a ser mi curva de la
demanda actual para mi computadora
portátil
además decirles también que estamos
suponiendo que todo es constante es
decir setter y es paribus y bueno ahora
vamos a pensar en la curva de la demanda
que vamos a dibujar también para este
automóvil económico y de igual manera
pasa lo siguiente si el precio es muy
alto entonces poca gente lo quiere
comprar mientras que si el precio es muy
bajo entonces mucha gente va a querer
comprar el automóvil también cumple la
ley de la demanda y por lo tanto aquí
está mi curva de la demanda que está
horrible entonces vamos a dibujar otra y
yo otra vez más aquí tenemos la curva de
la demanda actual ahora lo que vamos a
pensar es cómo va a cambiar la curva de
la demanda de estos dos bienes según los
cambios que tengamos en el ingreso es
decir nos vamos a centrar en el factor
del ingreso cuál es el efecto que tiene
el ingreso en nuestros bienes que vamos
a comprar bueno en un principio vamos a
suponer que el ingreso el ingreso de la
población se va hacia arriba
y para empezar pensemos en la
computadora portátil qué pasa si yo ya
tengo más dinero para gastar bueno lo
que va a pasar es que en cualquier punto
de este precio la cantidad va a aumentar
es decir la cantidad de personas que van
a demandar una computadora va a aumentar
porque ellos ya tienen más ingresos esto
quiere decir que si el ingreso de la
población aumenta entonces la demanda va
a aumentar dicho en otras palabras la
curva de la demanda se va a trasladar
hacia la derecha entonces vamos a
escribir lo que está pasando aquí es que
la demanda aumenta la demanda se cuenta
y bueno esto tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo porque ahora imagínate
que el ingreso de la población disminuye
es decir cada vez pagan menos pues por
lo tanto lo que va a pasar es que cada
vez menos personas van a querer comprar
una computadora portátil y por lo tanto
la demanda disminuye y esto también va a
ser el caso para otros bienes que en
estos bienes en los cuales la demanda
aumenta cuando los ingresos aumentan y
viceversa cuando los ingresos disminuyen
entonces la demanda va a disminuir se
les conoce
los bienes normales por lo tanto voy a
decir que esta computadora portátil es
un bien normal lo voy a escribir aquí
ahora vamos a pensar qué es lo que va a
pasar con el automóvil más económico del
mercado
bueno pensemos qué es lo que va a pasar
si los ingresos aumentan bueno imagínate
que la gente tiene mucho dinero o al
menos tiene un mejor sueldo y por lo
tanto la gente se va a preguntar ya que
tengo un poco más de dinero porque me
voy a tener que comprar el automóvil más
barato del mercado y es que en general
eso es lo que pasa si tú tienes un poco
más de dinero piensas en comprarte un
automóvil mejor podríamos pensar que
esto pasa en la mayoría de los casos en
este precio de este punto lo que va a
suceder es que la gente como ya tiene un
poco más de dinero va a decir espera yo
creo que mejor me voy a comprar un
automóvil un poco mejor
quiero un automóvil más elegante para
poderlo presumir bien con las personas
del trabajo con las personas de mi
universidad y bueno estudia te da idea
de qué es lo que va a suceder toda la
gráfica entera se va a recorrer en esta
ocasión hacia la izquierda y en este
caso date cuenta que cuando el ingreso
aumentó entonces fue
para este bien porque pues porque la
gente va a querer comprar un bien un
poco mejor y por lo tanto no van a
consumir este producto a todos los
productos a todos los bienes que les
ocurre esto se les conoce como bienes
inferiores dicho de otra manera son los
bienes con los cuales cuando la gente
tiene más dinero se consumen menos o
veámoslo desde la otra perspectiva si
entonces el ingreso se va hacia abajo
por lo tanto más gente va a querer
comprar un automóvil económico y
entonces lo que va a suceder es que la
demanda ha aumentado la curva entera se
traslada hacia la derecha y si lo
piensas por un momento parece ser una
situación bastante extraña imagínate la
gente diciendo o novak estoy perdiendo
mi trabajo me voy a comprar entonces el
automóvil más económico que existe y sin
embargo realmente esto es lo que pasa es
decir cuando el ingreso disminuye por lo
tanto la demanda aumenta y recuerda que
cuando estamos hablando acerca de la
demanda estamos diciendo que toda esta
curva entera se va a recorrer hacia la
derecha para cualquier punto de esta
gráfica entonces la cantidad demandada
aumenta porque recuerda que estamos
diciendo
este es el automóvil más económico del
mercado y entonces resumiendo para un
bien normal se aumenta el ingreso por lo
tanto la demanda aumenta y para un bien
inferior lo que va a suceder es lo
contrario si el ingreso aumenta entonces
la demanda disminuye es decir cuando el
ingreso aumenta la gente no quiere
comprar este producto quiere comprar un
producto un poco mejor y espero que todo
esto te haya dejado las cosas mucho más
en claro así que mejor nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo